[Müzik]
utangaç bir Çocukluğum vardı çok içine
kapanık bir genç kızdım sosyal olmak
herkese bir olmayı çok istiyordum ama
daha doğum anında yaşadığım travmadan
dolayı olsa gerek bir doğum travmasıyla
dünyaya geldim
20'li yaşlarımın Sonunda kendimi çok
mutsuz bir zamanda buldum hayatımda
istemediğim bir evlilik İçinden nasıl
çıkacağını Bilemediğin bir durum vardı
ve şöyle bir rüya gördüm rüyamda
Deniz kenarındayım
denize atlıyorum ve yüzmeye başlıyorum
açıklara doğru yüzüyorum yüzüyorum böyle
denizin ortasında bir kayalıklara
geliyorum
kayalıklara tırmanıyorum en Tepede bir
Sunak var ver Ver verdem büyük bir Sunak
sunan üzerinde
demirden bir kafes duruyor
gidiyorum kafesin yanına kafese
bakıyorum içinde canlı atan Bir Yürek
Var
gördüğüm an kendi Yüreğim olduğunu
anlıyorum
kafeslemişim
kafesi kaldırıp yüreğimi serbest
bırakmak istiyorum fakat o sırada elimin
üzerine bir gölge düşüyor kafamı
kaldırıp baktığımda dev bir Kartal
duruyor kafesin yanında
diyorum ki kafesi kaldırırsam Kartal
yüreğimi yiyecek kaldıramıyorum kafesi
geriye çekiliyorum duruyorum
ama kafesi kaldırmazsam hayatım boyunca
kafeslenmiş bir yürekle yaşayacağım
bunu yapamam artık yapamam diyorum ve
kafesi kaldırmamla birlikte Kartal
yüreğimi yiyor
ve yüreğim uçmaya başlıyor kartalla
yüzleştiğimiz zaman
yüreğimiz kanatlanıyormuş ve bu sefer
Şunu fark ettim
ezberlediğim bir metinle geldim
kafeslenmiş Yüreğim güvenli alanım
ama bir de size iletmek istediğim kalbin
şifasını travmayı
ölümleri Kolektif travmaları anlatmak
istediğim
bu duyguyu geçirmek istediğim bir yer
var ve bu kafesle kalırsam Muhtemelen
bunu yapamayacağım Güven ne olacağım
hani gene belki alkışlarsınız ama
bir de dedim Acaba bugün tekrar bu
kafesi kaldırabilir miyim tekrar
yüreğimi kartala sunabilir miyim
ve İşte o kartala sunma kararım ve
hayatımızda galiba bunu defalarca
yapmamız gerekiyor Bir seferde olmuyor
beni bugün bu TED sahnesine taşıdı
yüreğimi izler oldum O gün bugün
uyandığım zamanlarda farkına vardığım
zamanlarda güvenli alana çok alışıp
çıkamadığım zamanlarda O kafesi kaldırıp
yüreğimi izliyorum yaptığım işin popüler
adı aile dizimi Aslında nesillerden
aktarılan tramvayla çalışıyorum
ve
olağanüstü bir işim var 20 yıldır
sayısız kadere tanık oldum
böyle her seferinde ne zaman ezberden
gitmeye çalışsam hiç
ezberden gidemediğim her seferinde beni
yaşamın hayatta kalma gücüne
yaratıcılığına hayran bırakan bir
mesleğin var
işin Özünde Ben aslında bir iz sürücüyüm
şimdi yıllar önce okuduğum bir kitap
vardı işte gene 20'li yaşlarımda bana
ilham veren kitaplardan Bu kitap
aborjinler hakkındaydı ve bir grup bilim
adamı
Avustralya'nın Çöllerinde yapacakları
bir gezide
yerli bir rehberle anlaşırlar yaşlı bir
iş sürücüyle
ve bu iş sürücü hakkında o kadar şeyler
anlatılmıştır ki Ne kadar acayip iş
sürdüğünü ne kadar müthiş hikayeler
anlatılmıştır bilim adamlarından bir
tanesi bunları çok abartılı bulur ve bir
akşam kamp ateşinin etrafında
otururlarken yaşlı sürücüye eder ki ya
der Madem o kadar iyi bir iz sürücüsün
Ben bir yıl önce şu dağdan eteklerinde
bir arkadaşımda bir yürüyüşe çıkmıştım
Hadi bakalım bizim izimizi sürebilir
misin der
yaşlı iz sürücüde hiçbir şey söylemeden
ayağa kalkar ve adım adım Onların bir
sene önce yürümüş oldukları yolda yürür
bilim adamı şok geçirir bunu nasıl
yapabildin Bir sene oldu Biz bu yolu
yürüyelim
yaşlıyı der ki çok kolay geçen sene
yürüyen sizin peşinize takıldım
şimdi mantıklı Zihnim bunun imkansız
olduğunu biliyor ama ben bunu okuduğum
zaman yüreğime bir ateş düştü
derinde bir yerde bunun mümkün olduğunu
bilen bir taraf var ve buna karşı da
muazzam bir özlemle istiyordum
Aborjin kültüründe Dream Time dedikleri
Türkçe'ye Rüya zamanı olarak
çevirebileceğimiz
bir başka gerçeklikten bahsedilir
bu başka gerçeklik bizim gündelik
hayatımızı kurduğumuz ve günümüzde tek
gerçeklik olarak inandığımız bilinçli
gerçeklikten çok farklıdır
bu Başka gerçeklikte rüya zamanda zaman
lineer değildir
tüm yaşanmışlıklara şimdi ve buradan
ulaşabiliriz
işte bu
Rüya zaman
bilinçli gerçeklikle uyuşmadığı zaman
bu Yani dışarıdan algılarımız bizim
beynimizin son gelişen bölümü bilinçli
farkındalığımız dışarıdan gelen algıları
sinyalleri algılar ve ona göre bir
gerçeklik yaratır fakat bir de içten
yükselen duyumsamalar vardır ve bu
duyumsamalar çok yoğun olduklarında
ilkel Beynimiz devreye girer ve İlker
Beynimiz
bizi çok farklı bir gerçeklik alanına
sokar Bu bahsettiğim Rüya zamanı
aborjinlerin bahsettiği Bu Rüya zaman
aile diziminde de bizim morfolojini alan
ya da
bilen alan dediğimiz yerdir
İşte ben de o gizemli halinin şu bu
dönemde hepimizin çokça duyduğu travma
denen o gizemli halin izini Bu Rüya
zamanında sürerim eşi gerçeklikte
anlamadığımızdan korkarız Çünkü bilinçle
açıklayamadıklarımız gerçekliğimizi
tehdit eder
bu gerçeklik algımızla içeriden yükselen
duyumsamalar örtüşmediği zaman bu
aradaki o hislere
rüyalarımızda masallarımızda Cinler
periler öcüler 3 harfliler olarak
adlandırırız ve onu bilinçli
gerçekliğimize dahil etmeye çalışırız
Çok şükür ki günümüzdeki Bu sinir
sistemi ve travma fizyolojisi
araştırmaları İşte bu efsanelerin
mitolojilerin olduğu kadar
travmanın da Mesken tuttuğu Bu Rüya
zamanın kapılarını aramaya başladı biraz
daha iyi anlar olduk burada Neyin
olduğunu
Peki nedir bu travma
bizim
beden beyin bütünlüğümüze düşen bir
yıldırımdır aslında
bu beden beyin bütünlüğümüz bütün
parçaları arasında elektrik
sinyalleriyle haberleşen muazzam bir
sinir aile kaplıdır ve bu sinir anında
Biz hazır olmadığımız bir zamanda baş
edebileceğimizden daha yüklü bir sinyal
bombardımanı geldiğinde
bu haberleşme alt üst olur ve bu
haberleşme anın bu düşen Yıldırımla
birlikte nasıl Yıldırım bir eve düşerse
evin sigortaları
atıyorsa bizim beyin beden bütünlüğümüze
de çok benzer bir sistem vardır bizde de
sigortalar atar Ama burada çok ilginç
bir şey olur ilkel Beynimiz yaklaşık 400
milyon yıllık bir hayatta kalma
tecrübesine sahip ilkel Beynimiz
daha kendisine oranla Henüz yeni doğmuş
olan bilinçli beynimize giden kan
akışını Keser Yani bizim beynimizde de
sigortalar atar fakat sigortalar sadece
düşünen Beynimiz de atar
Peki bu ne demek oluyor Hani asırlar
öncesinde hepimizin bildiği şu meşhur
söz vardır
dekartın sözleri Düşünüyorum öyleyse
varım
peki Eğer travma anında bizim düşünen
Beynimiz devre dışı kalıyorsa burada var
olan
duyumsayan nefes almaya devam eden
kimdir peki
bize ne olur travma anında işte ne olur
özne Yeter artık burada anonim bir
varlık oluruz yani travma sinir
sistemimize düştüğü zaman Sinir
sistemimizin kaldırabileceğinden daha
büyük bir korkuyla bir dehşetle
çarpıldığımız zaman burada artık Feride
yoktur burada artık korku vardır ve
burada İlker Bey'in devreye girdiği gibi
bilinçli beyne giden kan akışını Keser
Çok da mantıklı bir nedeni vardır bunu
kesmesinin Çünkü bilinçli beyne bütün bu
bilgilerin gidip orada karar verip
Onlara göre harekete geçmemiz arasında
kaybettiğimiz zamanda oradaki Kaplan
bizi yiyebilir öyle bir lüksümüz yoktur
Dolayısıyla düşünme sistemi devrede dışı
kalır ve otomatik pilota geçeriz
İşte bu otomatik pilottayken
adonim bir varlık oluruz orada benden
öncekilerin bu tehlike karşısında
yapmış oldukları ve başarmış oldukları
stratejiler Ben daha düşünmeden devreye
girer hayatı sürdürmek adına Çünkü
buradaki en öncelikli şey yaşamın
devamıdır Feride'nin bireysel mutluluğu
değil
işte burada dünyamızda ister inan ister
inanmayın
1600 futbol sahası büyüklüğünde
binlerce ton ağırlığında
yaşı yaklaşık 5.000 yıl tahmin olduğu
tahmin edilen muazzam bir organizma
Yaşar ama hiç kimse bu organizmayı
görmemiştir Çünkü bu organizma toprağın
altında Yaşar adı bal mantarıdır
binlerce dönümlük araziyi kaplar yerin
altında yerin üstünde de böyle minik
minik şapkalı saplar verir
dışarıdan baktığımızda şapkalı saplara
birey olarak gözükür ama aslında
toprağın altında hepsi birbiriyle
bağlantılıdır
şimdi bu trağımı da bize neyi gösteriyor
birey olduğumuz zaman farklı
kaderlerimiz var ama Toprağın altına
baktığımızda belki burada ben birey
olarak 54 yaşında bir kadınım ama
Toprağın altına baktığımızda Benim sinir
sistemim yüzbinlerce yıldır benden önce
yaşamış olanların
hayatta kalma stratejileri ile
şekillenmiş durumda
işte burada size bir iki örnek vermek
istiyorum aile diziminde Biz Rüya zamana
geçeriz
gelen örneklerden bir tanesi Danışan
bana
kronik uykusuzluk sorunu ile gelmişti
uykusuzluk
geceleri hiçbir şekilde uyuyamıyordu ve
bana anlattığı
[Müzik]
bilgiler doğrultusunda Biz
Danışanın ailesinden birkaç kişiyi
koyduk ve koymakla birlikte bu size
bahsettiğim başka gerçekliğe geçiyoruz
ve o başka gerçeklikte öyle biriyle
karşılaştık ki
Danışanın dedesinin abisi 15 yaşında
Kurtuluş Savaşı'na gitmişti ve geri
dönmemişti
İşte bu ağabeyi
hala savaş alanında Nöbet tutmaya devam
ediyordu
öyle bir azimle öyle bir inançlı Nöbet
tutmaya devam ediyordu öyle bir yüz yıl
olmuştu Ama hala orada ve nöbet
tutuyordu
torunu getirdik
2020'li yıllara geldik artık ölebilirsin
dedik gözünü
o zaman hakkımıza geldi acaba
başkomutanı sokarsak alana ondan duyarsa
bunu olur mu diye ve başkomutanı
temsilen alana soktuk komutan girdi ve
dedi ki asker nöbet bitti Savaşı
kazandık ve İşte o anda
o yüz yıldır nöbette olan bu Danışanın
aile sisteminde de hala aktif Nöbet
tutmaya enerjisi olan
büyük amca
ağlamaya başladı artık ölebilirim dedi
ve gözlerini Kapattı şimdi çok enteresan
bir zamandayız travmanın tekrar doğası
vardır ve travmanın tekrar duası genelde
yıl dönümlerinde bireysel hayatta fakat
Kolektif travmaları da
Asır dönemlerinde ortaya çıkar
şimdi
bu 6 Şubat depremi olduğu zaman bende
travmanın izini süren biri olduğunda
Kolektif travma ile karşılaştığımda
hemen
bu cümleleri güçlü cümleleri ve yıl
dönümlerine neye denk geldiğine bakarım
sürekli kulağımda yankılayan cümle şuydu
kefensiz ölüyoruz kefensiz gömülüyoruz
Bu cümleler benim içimde İstiklal
Marşı'mızın düşün altında binlerce
kefensiz yatanı ile örtüştü
Kurtuluş savaşımızın 100 yıl dönümünde
biz tekrar toprağa on binlerce kefensiz
verdik biraz daha geriye gidip 200 yıl
geriye gidersek
1822'de de
büyük Hatay depremine geliriz ve bu
büyük Hatay depreminde
on binlerce kişi ölmüştür yaklaşık 60
bin olduğu düşünülüyor Yani gene toprağa
on binlerce kefensiz vermişizdir
İşte bu da Sizin söylemek istediğim Eski
Mısır'da
Malatya diye bir tane vardır mat
bleleri ölümün kapısında bekler ve eğer
ölüme geçerken
Yüreğiniz bu deve kuşu tüyü kadar
hafifse
ebedi huzura kavuşabilirsiniz Ama eğer
yürekleriniz taşlaşmışsa
travmalarla yoğunlaşmışsa İşte o zaman
Arafta kalırsınız
Benim de şöyle bir çağrım olacak
gereksiz olanları bırakalım yüreğimizi
bu toplumun Kolektif travmalarına da
açalım
ölürken hafif yürekle çıkalım Batın
karşısına ki mirasımız sevgi olsun
gelecek nesillere ışık olsun Çok
teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]